معارك تستعر في المنطقه الشرقيه والجنوبيه
من اوكرانيا على حد سواء كانت القوات
الروسيه تتقدم في عده محاور فيزا باروجي
واعلن عن هدوء او يعني طرح هدوء في
المعارك في منطقه زبروجي من ناحيه روسيا
لكن الجانب الاوكراني استمر بقصف عده مدن
تابعه للجانب الروسي لكن يعني فوجئنا
باعلان انفجار او فيديوهات ظهرت الانفجار
كبير قالت السلطات هناك في زبروجات تابعه
لروسيا بان هذا الانفجار يعني اسفر عن
قتيل ضابط شرطه وانه ان سببه الاساس هو
عمل ارهابي ان هناك مازال من يتعامل مع
الجانب الاوكراني من اجل يعني خلق البلابل
والمشاكل داخل المناطق التي تسيطر عليها
روسيا لكن المحاور الاخرى احمد اذا سمحت
لي بالفعل تشهد استعارا بالمعارك
خاصه ضخموت التي اعلن
نائب او مستشار القائم باعمال مقاطعه
التابعه لروسيا بانه بان الجيش الروسي قاب
قوسين او ادنى من اكمال الدائره السيطره
على شكل دائره حول باقمت اذا اكملت
السيطره على باقمه بشكل دائره فهذا يعني
قطع الامدادات حتى الصفر اي ان الجيش
الاوكراني سيكون محاصر وستنفذ ذخيره لكن
حتى الان ما دام الحديث عن عدم الاكمال
الكامل اذا هناك امدادات ما زالت تصل
للقوات الاوكرانيه داخل باخموت وما زالت
تقاتل حرب شوارع او قتال شوارع في الناحيه
الجنوبيه والناحيه الشرقيه من المدينه
قوات فاجنر تقاتل هناك وتحاول اختراق
المدينه من منطقه ايفانوفكا في الناحيه
الجنوبيه ومن مراكز يعني مع اللحوم ومسالك
اللحوم في المنطقه الشرقيه المنطقه
الشرقيه يوم امس شاهدت معارك عنيفه بالفعل
وحاولت القوات الروسيه التقدم في هذا
المحور كما ان المحور الشمالي من المنطقه
نحو
ايضا تقوم قوات فاجنر بمحاوله اختراق
المدينه محاولات كثيره مغطاه بالقصف
المدفعي والصاروخي قاتلات روسيه باتت بشكل
دائم طول النهار يعني يعني تتجول في سماء